it's time for The Adventures of Indiana
Jim
[Music]
this has been the adventures of Indiana
Jim
[Music]
hey there folks I'm Walter Benes Enoch
I'm how the roofs and I'm Adelaide and
this is top five last week we took a
look at Indiana Jones best movie moments
but we all know that this series has
some major flaws yeah I'm just feeling a
little congest
chucks I'm sorry no you know what I'm
not sorry crystal skull sucks it does
all three of us agree that it does I
remember being so disappointed seeing
this in theaters for the first time and
from beginning to end
Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull is just as bad now as it
was when it was released in 2008 but the
question is do all five of the worst
moments in the franchise belong to the
fourth installment yes
no no no don't spoil it whatever these
are the top five worst Indiana Jones
movie moments number five
nuclear bombs are one of the deadliest
weapons that humans have ever created it
will decimate everything in its path
except your refrigerator apparently I
understand that there is a certain level
of suspension of disbelief that is
required for an Indiana Jones movie Indy
has been on plenty of unbelievable
unsurvivable adventures but this this is
too far
KGB agents have kidnapped Indy and taken
him to a US military base with a
warehouse full of ancient treasures that
was seen at the end of Raiders so much
for that mystery he of course escapes
and ends up being chased through a fake
town built for nucular testing the
countdown begins in Indiana must find a
way to survive he spots a fridge that is
lined with lead that should protect him
from the blast and radiation this
actually doesn't bother me too much
seems like there is some kind of logical
thought that Indy might be able to
protect himself with in a lead-lined box
the next part is what really gets me
after the blast the fridge goes flying
through the air over the bad guys car
just as it is destroyed it tumbles
multiple times down a hill until it
comes to a stop
Indy just rolls out completely unscathed
really not a single injury and how did
that fridge even stay shut there all of
that there is absolutely no way he would
have been alive after that not even
considering that it was a nuclear blast
guess it's good to know that all
refrigerated foods would be safe and on
irradiated after a nuclear disaster
number 4
what are some of your biggest fears
spiders
clouds the creeping feeling of darkness
Dino Rob's return to plague us all how
about ants sure yes
Indiana and the king are being chased
through the forest they crashed right
into the home of some big man everyone
makes a run for it before the ants can
get them one of the KGB guards falls to
the ants and is eaten by them Indy Oxley
and a KBG agent are left behind to fight
amongst the killer ants Oxley falls and
reveals the Crystal Skull to the ants
who then make a rather large area for
indeed to fight the KGB agent it might
make sense for the ants to avoid the
skull if it did have some kind of
otherworldly power but why would they
make such a large arena for them to
fight in meanwhile the woman has found
higher ground so the ants build a living
pyramid to reach her only one of the
ants makes it to her and she squashes it
with her thighs and gets ant blood all
over the camera it looks incredibly fake
and um back in the ant maid fight ring
Indy is losing the battle until the
other guy lets him get his hat I guess
he just completely stops fighting and
watches as Indiana grabs a tree branch
to beat him with until he unconsciously
falls into the sea of ants who then
swarm him and take him to their nest
it's another nonsensical lackluster
scene in an already troubled movie
number three
oh I'm sorry is it really distracting to
try to learn to be talking while they're
eating gross stuff in the background
yeah no kidding in the Temple of Doom
Indiana Jones meets with the Thuggee
cult his traveling companions Willie and
shortround
must sample the local cuisine they're
served snakes surprise beetles and
chilled monkey brains for dessert
Willie's over-the-top reactions are
meant to show just how cool and calm
Indiana stays throughout the film and
this scene is no different
however the humor doesn't play here and
it distracts from the exposition
happening between Indy and one of the
cult leaders the gross-out humor is
redundant since we see them having to
walk on bugs later and we have plenty of
other examples of Willie not handling
change well the film was originally set
to film in India but with the caveat of
local governments final approval of the
script many audiences assumed this
spread was meant to portray typical
Indian meals and unfortunately it comes
off as racially muddled and simply put
it has not aged well number two
[Music]
there's a lot to unpack here the
Russians and Indies gang are in a
high-speed chase through the jungle
they're both desperate to hold on to the
Crystal Skull as it pops back and forth
when the vehicles they're driving after
a sword fight with Colonel Spock Oh mutt
Williams is hung up on a vine as the
chase continues without him moments
later he swings back in like Tarzan to
attack the bad guys with some new monkey
friends of his I want to talk about Shia
LaBeouf first there's always going to be
a certain fondness for me and seeing him
do anything on the big screen growing up
with even Stevens I will always be
rooting for Shia to do well now having
said that I think we all know Shia being
cast as the son of Indiana Jones was way
off base the character of mut Williams
was not written well presented well or
played well he's a drag on an already
horrible movie I don't know what David
co-op and Steven Spielberg were thinking
when coming up with mutt but whatever
they were trying to accomplish it failed
I think this moment in particular
solidified his place in Indy infamy the
artificial environment of the jungle
already put a bad taste in everyone's
mouth and the vines and monkeys were
just insult to injury
having mut literally swing on them until
he reached the cars was too much
ridiculousness to handle not to say that
the good Indiana Jones movies don't have
their fair share of ridiculous stunts
but this felt about 10 miles past that
line
I gotta mention the Jumanji monkeys too
this was 2008 not 1995 there's no excuse
for how bad this CG was combine all
those elements together and you
absolutely have the second worst moment
in franchise history
[Music]
[Applause]
in the number-one work Indiana Jones
movie moment if I want to know tell me
I'm ready I want to know
[Music]
actually I don't think I want to know
this is basically the whole ending of
the movie from when Colonel Spock Oh is
infused with the alien knowledge to the
alien itself showing up an Indiana Jones
standing in front of a giant flying
saucer all of it all of it is the worst
moment this is supposed to be the climax
of the film and none of it feels earned
the pacing of the whole story from start
to finish was a jumbled mess it was
confusing it was baffling and even
incoherent at some parts that alien
showing up and taking Sparkle with it to
the space between spaces felt like a
more than watered down call back to the
arc opening from Raiders or Donovan
rapidly aging in the Last Crusade
this whole movie actually kind of feels
neutered like that but it was especially
obvious here and the aliens thing in
general look I used to absolutely hate
that aliens were the main part of the
plot in an Indiana Jones movie that's so
stupid I used to think that doesn't fit
at all I used to say years later upon
deeper thought my views have changed on
that end slightly if utilized correctly
aliens could have absolutely fit in with
the Indiana Jones aesthetic I understand
they were going for the 50s UFO flick
vibe here and in theory that could have
worked
however the execution is atrocious there
wasn't a sufficient amount of time to
build up the mystery of the aliens or
even introduce them into this world we
start the movie on the Russians making
Indy dig one up at the fan service
facility where's the bill where is the
logical sequence of events this was a
cluster of crap and that's why by the
time we get to the end of the movie and
we see that shot of Indy watching the
flying saucer come to life from beneath
the temple it feels so wrong and it
still feels wrong it's out of place not
because it's an alien spacecraft but
because they failed to make an
interesting enough concept with a proper
time for us to care and somewhat
understand that's the main reason why in
d4 sucks in my book but hey create a
four ain't bad right if this fifth movie
is ever really going to happen I hope
they learn from their mistakes and
deliver something we all can once again
enjoy make sure you guys check out my
new show fan scription in it we
theorized how things would have played
out if big events in film history took a
different turn in our first episode
we asked what if Apollo Creed survived
his fight with Ivan Drago and rocky for
that episode is up now right here on
channel awesome also speaking of Indiana
Jones type adventure movies you guys
remember Vernon Wells from commando Mad
Max - the road warrior and Power Rangers
time forest well I'm in a movie with it
yes really and yes that's my real hair
it's called City of Gold and it will be
available on Amazon Hulu iTunes Google
Play and more on Tuesday December 4th
with a DVD release on January 1st 2019
if you're in the UK the movie is already
out under the title the lost city of
gold
I have an interview up with a director
of the film over on my personal channel
now so check that out for more
information or go straight to city of
gold the movie dot-com to pre-order we
want to hear what you guys think what's
your least favorite Indiana Jones movie
moment what do you want to see us cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
us know to keep in touch you can like my
Facebook page or follow along on Twitter
you can find me on Facebook Twitter
Instagram or subscribe to my animated
movie review series right here on
YouTube and you can find me on Twitter
Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Wednesday nights we'll catch you right
back here next week with something a
little more seasonal and a brand new
episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you